[Music]
okay everybody i am
so excited today because i am joined by
jay pharaoh aka jason and cinqua walls
aka caleb and the new film
resort to love that comes out this
thursday on netflix how you guys doing
today
very good pretty good man good man um
jay who did you think i was when i uh
was coming in here
no she said steve bart she said steve
from the steve barley show but the way
the way the way my ears are set up i
heard steve
from the steve harvey show i was like oh
and then i saw you and i was like well
this definitely ain't steve harvey
it's amazing um so so me being steve
barley not steve harvey
um my question for you jay for the
interview is filming in a beautiful
location
like you do in this film do you find it
harder to get work done in that
environment
or is it easier in a sense actually
there's more uh
it's it's more of an atmosphere of
serenity so you can get a lot more
uh you can get a lot more done you just
you just can't
even when you're you know even days when
you're not shooting and you're
you're just chilling you just your
mindset is to is to be aligned and get
everything
complete i remember when i got home
after i left the island i just cleaned
for like
five days i was like oh this is terrible
i can't because we had
butlers and maids and that it was nice
we had butlers
they were cleaning stuff up it was
pretty i i remember him telling me that
story too like everybody was going back
to that normal lodge in l.a and jay was
like i went back to clean
amazing okay that that's that's
hysterical and sinclair my question for
you is
you know i'm watching this film some of
the looks jay gives you are
absolutely like hysterical and i'm
wondering for you and your perspective
are you ever breaking on set with that
and is there a tip you can have for
actors not to break
not to not to not to break in a scene
that's really funny
yeah you know it depends on who you're
working with because some people
some people think they're funny and
they're not funny and then it's easy for
you to not break because it's like that
joke is not really
hitting me anywhere it was very
challenging
with jay because jay is naturally
really funny and really talented so you
just start watching the performance
and then you get in you get engaged in
it so it was challenging
in a good way because i feel like i i've
said this a couple times i felt like i
was getting to watch a show for free
that i should be paying
but that's because my brother's funny
and if he wasn't i would be with
tips to all actors on how not to break
in a scene
work with people who aren't funny and
you won't ever
i love that so you guys see how fun
these guys are
check them out this thursday and resort
to love on netflix they're funny but
they also do amazing job doing serious
moments it's exciting for both
of them in their career at this time so
thank you jay and cinco for joining me i
hope to talk to you guys in the future
thank you man thank you thank you so
much